hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about the way in which a fungal
pathogen known as Histoplasma
capsulotomy causes infection in human
hosts so first let's talk about where it
comes from it is in a mold form when
it's found in the environment and so
this is kind of what the mold form looks
like it produces a few different kinds
of spores for reproduction in the
environment so there are micro Kuna do
which would be small ones and macro
comitia which are the larger ones
and in particular its found in soil that
has been contaminated by droppings from
birds and bats and so how does it get
into humans
well when humans encounter soil that's
been contaminated by these droppings if
they disturb the soil for example
perhaps they are in a cave with a lot of
bats and they're disturbing the guano
that builds up those background things
or if they're doing sort of farming type
activities anything that might disturb
the soil that will result in these
different kinds of spores becoming
aerosolized and then they can actually
be inhaled by the human who disturbed
the soil and in particular these micro
Canadia which are most likely to be
inhaled this way so they get inhaled
they enter the human body into the lungs
and there's not actually any
reproduction of this fungus inside the
human body usually however the warmer
temperature in the lungs causes all of
the spores that are inhaled to transform
into a different sort of phenotypic life
stage of the fungus known as East's so
into yeast or budding yeast cells so no
longer this mold form but this sort of
unicellular yeast form instead and the
yeasts then get phagocytosis
now during this initial sort of period
of infection there are some symptoms
that are similar to flu or tuberculosis
or serious respiratory type symptoms
now phagocytosis is when Salsman immune
system engulf the yeast cells in order
to degrade them and get rid of them
unfortunately it tends to not work out
so well these phagocytic cells can't
really handle the yeast so much
and they end up the yeast cells end up
traveling through SATA sites throughout
the entire body so becomes very
disseminated through the body and in
there traveling via the bloodstream and
in particular they're traveling in the
blood to lengthen elements and to the
rest of the body and what ends up
happening is we get later symptoms of
inflammation of the entire chest cavity
from this infection as well as
enlargement of the spleen and swelling
of the lymph nodes and this is because
these phagocytes are kind of clogging up
the lymph nodes causing them to swell
being filtered out by the spleen which
really can't get rid of them very well
and that causes the spleen to be quite
enlarged and so these are later symptoms
of the infection caused by Histoplasma
cuts a lot of which is called
histoplasmosis and it can be fatal if
it's not treated luckily there are some
various types of antifungal drugs that
one can take in order to treat an
infection and that histoplasmosis
disease and so this is how if the plasma
capsule Atum causes infection and human
hosts if you're interested in some other
pathogen lifecycles see my playlist on
pathogen lifecycles these will include
things like the requirements justice'
meiosis life cycles you can also check
out my video on introduction to fungal
pathogens to learn more about other
types of fungi that cause disease in
humans so that's it for today thanks for
watching biology professor